do everything plaid is just an over
opinionated stripes hmm icing plaid
probable is sinking too hard yeah it's
like hey stop it buddy yeah the trying
so hard why are you doing so much I
don't know
I enjoy you in the parallel why are you
also horizontal I think that all the
time really
Oh Jess I'm in a jail of those thoughts
in my head all the time
I'm sorry Oh like did you ever watch the
Fraggle hold on to bed yeah I love it
yeah Fraggle Rock when you think back on
that like that's some weird right Oh
watch out that boys who are building and
then we're eating it we're eating the
building and then they go above ground
and they see a human and that's their
worst fear isn't that just a metaphor
for you to keep job don't upload if I
see an actual human I will have a panic
subscribe you were talking about this
little earlier when you we were talking
about beans
mamrie Hart's dog and that beans is so
cute you want to kick it yeah and so my
question is what do you think is the
best thing in the world to kick I think
it's a very great question mm-hmm I
think sometimes very cute dog of course
yes cute dog sleeping nice oh look I
would like to just get I love you let's
grab you and kick like a lot spydra's
bomb down the fields let's let you
question you know your control in the
world forever with this one moment yeah
it's very difficult yeah so cute go away
what do you think is the worst inanimate
object to be covered with human skin um
I would say in my grade - yeah I was
having science project I was making a
bit parents project yeah I was making a
pyramid a pyramid and added a slip this
is very weird only one time in a life
will it occur slip and then I fall on
the pyramid and then the point is in one
of my lobsters and then so my fault like
0.8 seconds my nose is covering a pure
so that is the worst object it's in
animation to have cover of skin what was
the last text message you sent can i
yeah you can check your phone I'll sip a
Bloody Mary while you do so it's long
and in German please regale us heard I'm
it off to ash Geiger it means a stop
with that you but violin oh okay and we
have arrived
Lola welcome to your challenge you can
open your eyes oh boy hey yeah
mine has a bite already I don't know no
one ate it I mean it's fresh and new it
looks so young from the fake okay the
challenge Flula but I have tailored
specifically for you
is based off of the cinnamon challenge
but here on not your dupe of grace Kovac
we are doing the cinnamon bun challenge
okay so the parameters are that we have
to eat a cinnamon bun faster than the
other person but there's a catch oh
that's our twist uh oh
we have to eat the duck table itself we
can't use our hands oh also cinnamon
buns are not complete without frosting
so we have frosting that we are going to
decorate each other's cinnamon buns with
okay so this blue just microwave the
frosting wasn't a warm it looks like bad
so um as Cheers
we are going to decorate each other
cinnamon bun before we begin this
challenge okay okay guys tell me when
when definitely hey buddy oh that's good
yeah oh let us stop it and Archie sauce
I'll be okay I'll be frugal
cougar what is this welcome to America
No everything is bigger here you can I
was going to go like this like hey buddy
little oh oh it's so cute but no you put
a mirror on you tried oh right so now
I'm duct taping yeah yeah this stop what
are we doing what if there's a fire have
ya more we didn't have on your mark get
set go
just s quiet very hot okay I'm here
buddy
this is tough now we're having fun
Jesus you did this to me oh well you
said something rude and so I was gonna
give you a drop of Foster it does feel
sex with you know someone out there it's
like this is my fetish actual eyes right
now say ah you're staring at us they're
loving it
Oh God pull up yeah I'm comes after me
who I'm from South Jersey and malls are
big culture all smiles
you know story places yeah well
purchases Omega do
yeah so I feel like I'm gonna turn into
my high school days new Texas in high
school like a little bit oh come back
thanks for watching don't forget to
listen to the full podcast on itunes on
subscribe to Flula on YouTube Oh hmm hey
if crosstie five-o do what I would touch
your fronts you want the package so ash
kaga is it this is a friend or are you
just on tinder whoo no no no I don't use
timber